in this video i'm going to assume that
you already know a few things and we've
covered this we've proved this in other
videos that sine of x plus y
is equal to sine of x cosine y plus and
then you swap
the cosines and the sines cosine of x
sine y
and that cosine of x plus y is equal to
cosine x cosine y minus sine x
sine y once again we've proven this in
these in other videos
and then there's some other properties
we know of cosine and sine that we have
looked at in other videos cosine of
negative x
is equal to cosine of x and that sine of
negative x
is equal to negative sine of x and that
of course
the tangent of something is defined as
sine
over cosine of that something now with
that out of the way
i want to come up with a formula for
tangent of x plus y
expressed just in terms of tangent of x
and tangent of y you can view it as the
analog
for what we did up here for sine and
cosine
well the immediate thing that you might
recognize is that tangent of
x plus y based on the definition of
tangent is the same thing
as sine of x plus y
over cosine of x
plus y and what's that going to be equal
to
well we know that sine of x plus y can
be expressed
this way so let me write that down so
that's going to be
sine of x cosine
y plus cosine of x
sine of y
and then and actually so that we can
save a little bit of writing i'm going
to
awkwardly write make the line here down
here because we're going to we're going
to put something here in a second but i
think you'll get the idea so that's
going to be that over cosine of x plus y
which is this expression when you just
express it in terms of cosines of x
and cosines of y and sines of x and
sines of y so let me write it here
so you're going to have cosine of x
cosine y minus
sine of x and then
sine y now we want to
express everything in terms of tangents
of x's
and y's and so it might make sense here
to say all right
well we know tangent is sine over cosine
so what if we were to divide both the
numerator and the denominator by some
expression
that can start to make the numerator and
denominator express in terms of tangents
and i will cut a little bit to the chase
here so in the numerator
what i can do is and i'm going to do
this just in the numerator and then i'm
going to do it in the denominator as
well
i'm going to divide the numerator by
cosine of x
cosine y and of course i can't just
divide the numerator by
cosine of x cosine y that would change
the value of the
this rational expression i have to do
that to the denominator as well
so i know this is a very complex looking
fraction here but it's going to simplify
in a second
so i'm also going to divide the
denominator by cosine of x
cosine of y and now let's see if we can
simplify this in certain ways on the in
the numerator we can see that this
cosine
y cancels with this cosine y and so that
first term becomes
write in another color here so this sine
of x over
cosine of x and so the numerator
i can say this is going to be equal to
sine of x over cosine of x
is tangent of x
and then this second term here we can
see
that this cosine of x cancels with this
cosine of x
and so we're left with sine of y over
cosine of y which is of course tangent
of y
so plus tangent of y
and then all of that is going to be over
now we can
look at the denominator so this first
term here we can see the cosine of x
cancels with the cosine of x and the
cosine of y
cancels out with the cosine of y so you
could view this first term here when you
divide by this
cosine of x cosine y it just becomes one
and then we're going to have the minus
and now this
second term is interesting we have
sine of x over cosine of x sine of y
over cosine of y
so sine of x over cosine of x
that over there is tangent of x and then
sine of y over cosine of y that's
tangent
of y so this is going to be tangent
of x times tangent of y
and just like that we have come up with
an expression for tangent of
x plus y that just deals with tangent of
x's
and tangent of ys now the next question
you might say well all right that's
great for tangent of x
plus y but what about tangent
of x minus y
well here we just have to recognize a
little bit of what we've seen
before let me write it over here tangent
of negative x is equal to sine
of negative x over cosine
of negative x and what's that going to
be equal to
and i know i'm running out of space this
is going to be equal to sine of negative
x is the same thing as
negative sine of x negative sine of x
and then cosine of negative x is just
cosine of x
well this is just the negative of the
tangent of x
so this is negative tangent
of x and the reason why that is useful
is i can rewrite this as being let me
write it here this is the same thing as
tangent
of x plus
negative y so everywhere we saw a y here
we can replace it with a negative y
so this is going to be equal to tangent
of x plus the
tangent of negative y
all of that over 1
minus the tangent of x
times the tangent of negative y
well we know the tangent of negative y
is the same thing as the negative
tangent of y and we know that over here
as well
so this could just be we could write the
tangent of y here and then the negative
would turn this into a plus
and so just to write everything neatly
we know that also the tangent of
x minus y can be rewritten as
tangent of x minus
tangent of y all of that
over 1 plus
tangent of x and tangent
of y